hey youtubers is Charlie this week for
my bonus video I wanted to talk all
about acai the place Melisandre comes
from the full name that people call it
is a side by the shadow the shadow
refers to the name of the region like
you would refer to the Dothraki sea for
those that don't know that's the area
where Daenerys is dragon eggs came from
there's a lot of similarities to the
Valyrian Peninsula which is dotted with
the 14 flames the 14 volcanoes so there
might be some active volcanoes up around
a side where we might be able to find
another clutch of dragon eggs a sigh
itself is mostly a trading city even
though the region is generally thought
of as being very sinister the problem is
is that it has a culture that predates
the Valyrian freehold but it's lost a
time the people that actually live there
have no idea who built the city most of
what we learn about it is through
anecdotes given by other characters
which you can't always trust a hundred
percent
the other big thing about the area is
its where shadow binders come from
that's the type of magic the mill sander
practices she's a shadow binder who is a
follower of the red God you can be one
without the other
although the dominant faith is real or
as you can see from the map because it's
so far east it's probably a place we're
never gonna get to see on the show which
is a bummer usually a lot of the context
that we get for stuff like this comes
from the expanded materials - it's
referred to in the Song of Ice and Fire
but it's not like somewhere where the
characters actually travel - or at least
we should say travel - yet because it
mean it's always possible that someone
could go there in the future this area
here's the Jade seat you know there's a
lot of trading that goes on its area
especially around Korth so usually when
we get stories it's from sailors like
the Ironborn people like you're on
Greyjoy it'd be nice if Melisandre
talked a little bit about her homeland
she's not super chatty when she's not
talking about the war of light and dark
there are certain areas in the world
though where Mel Sanders says her power
is greater so like like an aside where
she trained that's where her power is
really great but at the wall right now
she says it's even greater there's
really no context to understand why that
is and even though it seems like the
series is positioning Daenerys as a
protagonist with her dragons against
White Walkers in the night's king which
a lot of people think are really evil
especially after last week's episode any
connection between Melisandre is power
and Dragons is is completely anecdotal
there's all the theories and everyone's
crossing their fingers hoping that some
ice dragon is gonna bust out of the wall
something like that there is evidence
that the wall might come down during the
series but we have no idea if that's
true when you look at the history of a
sigh in the Shadowlands it gives you
better context with which to frame the
night's king and the White Walkers
really just two sides of a coin it's not
so much about good and evil even even
George R Martin when all the craziness
with Sansa happened after episode 6 he
did a big interview where he said my
stories are all about struggle you know
not so much about good and evil I just
think it means that even though Daenerys
and her dragons might seem like the
diametric opposite of the night's king
in his army of White Walkers it doesn't
necessarily mean that Daenerys or her
dragons are good characters there's a
lot of people hoping that Daenerys might
end up being the villain of the series I
don't know if that's gonna be the case
but you know like last week's episode
she got those crazy eyes when she talked
about crushing the nobles of Westeros I
think that's her just showing more
agency saying you know this is what I
want to do this is what I believe in
this is why I want to do it if you're
getting a vibe of the Mad King off of
her that's Stan and Dave just messing
with you a little bit they want you to
see that as a possibility
that's why Tyrion entered the equation
because now that he's there hopefully
he'll give her some good advice
Daenerys in the context of this series
it is still a little kid who has some
really powerful dragons so it's like
giving a little kid the keys to a car
it's just no matter what you do
something terrible's gonna happen
Tyrion as bitter as he is seems like he
generally has the best interests of the
world at heart he's not a bad person
despite the fact that he's full of hate
I mean he still wants to help people
at some point they will have to meet
Melisandre I think that's the point
where they'll really start to blur the
lines between good and evil I mean you
know we saw the White Walkers last week
and they seem pretty terrible you know
raising up an army of zombies just
screams evil but that's only because it
was happening to Jon Snow who the series
is positioned as the protagonist anyone
who goes up against a person that looks
like a hero is gonna seem like a villain
and as mysterious as Melisandre seems
right now she hasn't done anything worse
than any of the protagonist characters
have done but she had to consider the
culture that she flows from the shadow
binders generally regarded as a really
hardcore Bunch
but there are places where they come
from you know up up in the shadow that
they're still afraid to go where
supposedly Dragons might be there's this
ancient city called stag I that lies way
up the ash river north of a side it's
thought of
at corp city but that is probably just
because nothing can survive there the
shadow binders are afraid to go there
they say the areas inhabited by by
really dark creatures demons and Dragons
because that area is also a peninsula
there are also a lot of caves that
pockmarked the coastline where clutches
of dragon eggs might be we don't know if
there are other dragons still living
there but there could be clutches of
dragon eggs especially if there are
volcanoes in the area to help preserve
them so if you were to say that dragons
are good you have to consider where they
come from if the place is called the
shadow and it's regarded by terrible
people as being a terrible place how
good can it be what I think ended up
happening is is that at some point a
volcano in that area or multiple
volcanoes erupted just you know covering
the area with ash making it impossible
for anything to live killing whatever
civilization originally inhabited the
area that's why the river probably came
to be known as the ash river there might
even still be an active volcano spewing
ash into the atmosphere the way I think
about it though is that the shadow to
the east is what the lands of always
winter are to the north the lands of
always winter are in a way up here we
saw them during season four briefly it's
the place that the White Walkers were
banished to after the long night they
retreated to the coldest place possible
it makes sense that at another point in
history Dragons did the exact same thing
just you know retreating to an area
pockmarked by volcanoes there's no
concrete evidence that dragons love
volcanoes only that ancient Valerians
first discovered dragons near the 14
flames which are the 14 volcanoes in the
Valyrian Peninsula the big take away
though is that you know if White Walkers
have started to pour out of the lands of
always winter that it would make sense
that at some point dragons are gonna
start pouring out of the Shadowlands
just remember that as evil as the night
King seems Melisandre and dragons come
from a very evil sinister place - that's
why I think Game of Thrones are so much
fun you have a character like Jon Snow
who is caught between a rock in a cold
place it's like he's accepting help from
Melisandre who seems just as terrible as
the night's king we just haven't gotten
any of the night's Kings story yet we
really don't know what he's trying to do
other than kill all of our main
characters in reality you know don't
think of dragons as evil creatures
they're really more like reptiles they
have their own intelligence it's all
about the person using them so if
dragons are sinister it's only because
Daenerys is using them in a sinister way
like when she's roasting people and
marine so here's my big question for you
guys you know given this added context
as bad as the White Walkers in the
night's king scene do you think that
Daenerys and her dragons are good
characters or do you think that they're
gonna be just as bad one of the
limitations of the TV show is that
because of all the stuff it cuts out you
don't get a lot of context you have to
look at shows like breaking bad where a
villainous character is the protagonist
that could be the direction the series
is going with Daenerys in her dragons
tonight's episode is called the dance of
the Dragons you know hopefully we'll get
to see some really awesome dragon stuff
so be sure to subscribe to get my video
I'll post it after the episode airs it's
actually a reference to a short story
that George R Martin wrote called the
dance of the Dragons I'll talk about
that a little bit more in my episode 9
video and don't forget there'll be a new
round of the giveaway too so just look
out for that video bye guys wait for
that to post if you want to learn more
about the rise of ancient Phileas you
can click here and you can click here
for last week's episode thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you